kuwait I can't believe this they have
developed some sort of futuristic
incredible gaydar that I thought only
gay people had that's right yosef mind
car sounds like dr. Mindbender from GI
Joe he is the director of public health
at the Kuwaiti Health Ministry and he
has he's given us this new gaydar let's
let's take a look at the quote health
centers conduct the routine medical
check to assess the health of
expatriates when they come back into the
GCC countries however we will take
stricter measures that will help us
detect gays who will then be barred from
entering Kuwait or any of the GCC member
states let's just look at the GCC member
states real quick
they are Bahrain Kuwait Oman Qatar or
Qatar depending on what day it is Saudi
Arabia and the United Arab Emirates so
these these are countries where
homosexual acts are banned we put that
list up let's get that list up one more
time
also known as America's closest allies
Middle East really these are these are
all considered allies in the United
States and maybe a Oman Oman come yeah
sure yeah well I bet so those are pretty
yeah all right so we're lined up with
these guys they're doing gaydar tests
before we get into it any further what
do you think this gaydar test might
entail god I don't know of lots of
fingers lots of fingers yeah I don't
know what they're gonna do but I hope my
brother doesn't have to go to Kuwait
because he's as straight as they come
but any gaydar test he's gonna fail yes
is a guy who gets a pedicure in the
Superbowl you can sure that song is
right in whatever they're doing there in
Kuwait I'm sorry sir
yeah I don't exactly know the Superbowl
but you can't commit right now I mean
even whatever they're right I'm not sure
of the methodology about they're going
about doing this but whatever it is
because this is so backwards it's going
to be things like that oh the guy has uh
you know nicely trimmed nails he's
obviously gay you get some bear from
West Hollywood they're not gonna think
he's gays big fat bear right guys I
think they were making fun of it right
but it just invites every dumb indirect
stereotype about gay people yeah what
about straight we're about gravy buddy
huh what does it say about the way
we choose our allies in the United
States because as you said all these are
our United States ally countries I get
obviously every country is different
everybody different laws we even have
gay marriage here the last couple months
so fine but should we have like a tiered
system of like you gotta have some basic
human rights to be our prime time Ally
Saudi Arabia we're pretty close to them
yeah you know women can't vote there
they can't drive suppose they're gonna
be able to vote in a couple years but
they will go to drive together only
stage they can vote for like dog catcher
like it's super super long municipal
elections yeah it's the low stuff
exactly so shouldn't we doesn't have
anything to do with how we pick our
allies that they we should just like a
basic set of standards like you gotta
treat your women equally before we're
allies does that seem to a should it
should be that way but it's more like
what can they offer us what we need is
there something that they have over
there that might take a look at that
list again yeah what is over there what
is that I don't know yeah does it start
with a no yeah I don't know there I or
new year old uh-oh yeah so of course and
obviously in a in a region that includes
you know uh the Taliban and al Qaeda in
you know Indian various elements in in
Yemen and Pakistan and Afghanistan and
other places as well obviously you know
so many of the 19 hijackers and on
September 11th came from Saudi Arabia
like it's freaking complicated you know
and so what he's supposed to do uh I
mean what's interesting though is that
if they had a test to determine in those
countries whether these people were
Jewish now that then we might actually
do some you know uh reco uh but you know
it could be similar to the gay test
because of the circumcision so there's
something it's something about the penis
uh right you know uh Houston well dress
so is it up in jail haha actually choose
art well yes they say yes does thing as
I said yeah chill out homeboy yeah it's
a you know like anytime you sort of
break down me look everybody wants us to
be allies with China and Russia that
makes sense but I mean but they don't
have great they have terrible human
rights records they've shameful human
rights records but it's better to be
friends of people and I think
it's better to influence change from
within unless they're doing something
particularly hideous like North Korea or
in the minds of some you know Iran yeah
do you think they ever realize how much
they're losing by not integrating gay
people like if you think of all the
great things all the great art and music
and almost every the clothes and
everything that usually comes from gay
people and they don't have any of that
it's a damn shame isn't the music of
Kuwait's taking a major yeah
Kuwaiti music would be like the most
part in a world that there's just a
couple of gay expats back in the country
you let like a gay one direction a
Kuwaiti one direction I mean my god baby
cue other as other Gaza One Direction
gay I don't even know what you wanted to
we'll see uh yeah so here's give a
couple years yeah well they say that uh
to one of the murders
yeah we'll discuss this off yeah there's
one part of the story that was great
because it Bahrain which is on that list
were they getting on that list yet uh uh
arrested a hundred twenty seven people
in 2011 for holding and this is a quote
from Gulf News yes uh for holding a
depraved and decadent party which for
the first time made me want to go to
Bahrain back but because I what do you
think that into what does that encompass
it's to pray me whatever their people
having sex in dark corners and you're
having sex with strangers gay straight
don't care a one into that party a party
for me
98% of the times like me in the corner
next to no one drinking a sprite zero
scan in the room for a television to
watch the game that I would be watching
if I stay at home and was enjoying
myself I think he would enjoy yourself a
lot more if you just had regular spray
spray it just salad is zero it's like
nothing you're drinking nothing actually
it was great as when I wrote that line I
had sprite and then and that I crossed
it out as I experienced funnier same
people and then it get like you come
back with it but the funniest line of
all it's perfect we tell you a little
something a little something about human
rights and a little something about
comedy in that segment there you go hey
guys rubin report
brought to you by Cooper comm you can
get up to 75% off pet toys choose all
kinds of treats and more the link is
right down below click it and use code
RR for 20% off your first purchase